foreign
s Us in Philadelphia Kelly welcome to
the show
hi thank you for taking the time to
speak with me today sure what's your
question
so uh let me preface this with saying
that I was
um previously involved in a financially
abusive relationship so I take Financial
Security very seriously
um and makes me nervous
um I am in a somewhat new relationship
um relationship I'm referencing was four
years ago so we're past that this new
relationship is moving along quickly
um however I just found out that they
have a significant amount of debt
um with not a lot of income and I'm just
not sure if it's something I should you
know try to work with them through or if
I'm just sort of putting myself in a bad
situation considering their Tendencies
to make poor decisions with money was he
hiding it and you found out or you were
just talking about it and he it's just
kind of coming up naturally
so it bits and pieces
um it started when we were talking about
the hypothetical wedding stuff and I
said you know given my history I was
leaning more towards separate accounts
the more I learned about you know this
program I learned that you want to be
able to share accounts but for sake of
the conversation
um I mentioned separate accounts and he
got really offended and I brought up I
was like well you've told me that you're
bad with money before and I didn't know
what that meant then he mentioned a low
credit score and I'm like well we got to
fix that before we get married I mean I
I can't have it in you know affect my
car insurance and all my rates and
everything I've worked too hard to get
where I'm at
um
four months wow we're already talking
about marriage
yeah and that's the other thing too is I
I sort of am kind of feeling like maybe
there's a reason why he's trying to move
like put you know put pressure on it he
knows that financially I'm secure I mean
I don't you know I'm not a millionaire
yet but do you think he's using you in a
sense of like well she's financially
secure I'm gonna hitch my cart to this
wagon yeah is he trying to freeze
I don't think that but I do know and I
he admitted that if I didn't push and
cry about what's your credit what do you
owe that he would have kept it from me
because I'm the only person in his life
he has ever told about his debt okay I
mean it may just come from a place of
Shame and guilt and baggage so if we're
going to give him the benefit of the
doubt but I agree we need to pump the
brakes on this relationship and here's
the thing we need to figure out values
and goals because people are willing to
change right I mean right I would never
say hey don't date a guy because he has
debt but if you say this guy says he's
fine staying in debt and he's fine where
he's at that's a huge red flag to me
yeah is he willing is is he actively
working to pay off some of this debt is
he is he saying things like yeah once I
get out of debt blah blah blah or you
know what what are his views moving
forward because just because you know he
started there that doesn't necessarily
mean that's his future so
yeah so
um we had to talk about it once I found
out that it's 70 grand and 50 of it was
required in the past two to three years
um by just credit card nonsense knowing
any spending money he didn't have and
you know he said he's willing to work
through I mean I went through a budget
with him and everything there's really
not there's like not a ton of money left
to spend he's willing to do it but I you
know I was open about my concerns that
it could happen again and he got very
defensive I would listen to this voice
Kelly what I'm going to do is send you
two copies of The Total Money Makeover
read through it with him and if he has a
heart change and he's ready to go gun
hoe and get rid of this stay with him